i [ __ ] guarantee you that you will be
making more than people who have
four-year degrees you'll probably start
making money by the end of the first
year i was at brooke's house and she had
seven 20 to 23 year olds at her house no
cat one morning one of the guys was up
early and he was like hey right now i've
got a thousand extra dollars like where
do you think i should invest it you know
i've got my 401k and i've got you know
whatever stuff and it was cute it was so
interesting to me because like he was
looking for an investment vehicle that
was going to yield him a return i want
to be very clear about this if you
invest in the s p 500 you know real
estate things like that and you start
really early and you do it for a long
period of time you absolutely will make
money it is a very safe way to live life
but the moment you start investing in
kind of the asset side of stuff which is
like the s p stocks in general and
you're not day trading or doing that
stuff because that's that's stupid the
moment you do that is actually the
moment in my belief that you're actually
ceasing to want to make more income hear
me out if you're 18 years old and you
graduate high school tomorrow you are
now eligible on the marketplace because
you have no skills besides your high
school diploma you did no job [ __ ] off
the whole time don't watch youtube to
learn stuff which is not you but just
imagine in two days you could go and
become certified as a phlebotomist and
go from making 750 or whatever the
minimum wage is to what phlebotomists
make at 25 an hour you would triple your
earning capacity after two days and
spending 500 if you can triple your
income for the rest of your life the 500
certification in two days do you think
it's worth the investment
probably and so the problem is that
people think about the biggest
investment as the stuff that they take
their money and they put it into and i'm
gonna be over i'm gonna be trite right
now your ability to earn money to
provide value to the marketplace and
solve problems for other people is how
you will be able to make money there's
the value of the problem that you solve
and what you charge for it the bigger
that number is the more you can charge
that gap between their old problem and
the solution that value is the
percentage that you can take and put in
your pocket as something that you have
now created in this and it could be a
service it could be products it could be
whatever your earning capacity is going
to be the thing that generates you
wealth do you want to be smart with your
money and save it absolutely because
that gives you way more that you can
play with but when you're 20 even when
you're 30 and in my belief whatever age
you are i believe that you should take
all of the excess money live as cheap as
you can take a hundred percent of that
excess money and invest it in education
that increases your earning capacity
because what happens is when you take
that money like that phlebotomy course
right you take twenty five dollars an
hour time two thousand hours a year
you're not a fifty thousand all year
income cool if i can live on 20 because
i'm 20 years old and i can live with
buddies and we can eat ramen soup and
whatever and i got 30 left over after
taxes 25 whatever 25 grand can buy you a
lot of education i would rather you or i
would rather me or somebody who's 20 or
somebody who's 30 take 2 000 a month
because that's what 25 grand is and
invest it in courses coaching
mentorships workshops and seminars every
month i'm putting that 2k now you could
put 2k into one opportunities you're
like dude i think real estate's cool
cool we're not doing real estate as my
passive income we're doing real estate
is i'm gonna get into the real estate
game and i'm gonna make it my active
income and by the way everybody who
builds their wealth and real estate are
actively spending their time in real
estate don't believe what they're saying
they're like dude i did this deal and i
made x amount of money it's like what
was the process of finding deals how
many deals did you look at how many
conversations did you have how many
buildings did you walk how many
different general contractors did you oh
wait there is and there's other stuff
that has to happen right back to the
point let's say that you take that 2 000
a month and you do that for four years
and i'm not saying do the four-year
degree i think that is play if you want
to i don't necessarily agree with it
anymore in the marketplace that
currently exists four years later i
[ __ ] guarantee you that you will be
making more than people who have
four-year degrees you'll probably start
making money by the end of the first
year the amount of like copywriting
courses in books and programs
mentorships and even one-on-one coaching
like i think one-on-one coaching is a
phenomenal way to learn a new skill if
you're like hey i need to know how to
buy media i need to know how to run an
ad go pay someone who runs ads or
teaches people how to run ads when you
make that payment you're seeing it as
one class in your entrepreneurial degree
rather than this one twelve thousand
dollar investment has to make me rich if
you can make that shift it's like this
is my course like when you get your
degree in college you're not like oh i'm
going to take one class in spanish
graduate and get whatever job i want no
one thinks that way but for some reason
to think about that when it comes to
entrepreneurial stuff you're not paying
someone to think that they're going to
be your savior they're not going to save
you from your life do everything for you
no one person is going to teach you
everything i'll do my best on this
channel teach the stuff i know but you
have something to learn from everyone
you know like that wasn't the value that
i thought i was like you can still learn
from that you want to go to the person
who's providing the most value for free
it's the easiest way for you to decrease
your risk of purchase if you follow
someone's instagram you follow youtube
you see the stuff they put out you're
like dude this is really good like this
is a lot of new information that i
didn't know and it's like very tactical
and i understand like hey you already
know that you like the person b you
already know that you're getting value
from the person from the content they
have and so the likelihood that the
thing that they have that's paid is
gonna be worse than that is low you know
hopefully follow lots of people in a
particular space see the one that you
jive with the most you like their
teaching style you don't need to follow
this stuff for forever to like belabor
the decision give yourself seven days
because you know what's really even
cooler than buying one person's buy em
all and then you'll know what everyone
knows and then guess what happens you
become just as good or better now you're
making eighty thousand dollars a year
well now we've got four thousand dollars
a month that we can spend on coaching
and mentorships and learnings and
courses and whatnot i was saying to
myself like i'm gonna be the number one
student here i'll just do whatever they
say i'll see what happens and i'll do
whatever they say i'll see what happens
you wanna replicate before you iterate
before you say i'm gonna put my alex
sauce on before you do that just make
sure that you can duplicate what they're
doing because then you earn the right to
make the iterations even if it's not
perfectly your style copy it first
before you make the iterations if you
see it as a bridge that has many bricks
on it you have to lay all the bricks and
here's the bad part let's say you've got
30 bricks on this bridge to make your
first dollar the first dollar has to
walk across the bridge when you're 28
bricks in you might not have made the
first dollar yet but you're 90 of the
way there and the speed with which
people are able to traverse or cross
that bridge is how well they identify
which brick is missing and where they
put their attention that's where a lot
of people get disheartened is that they
will start building new bridges and get
two three bricks and then they'll start
building a new bridge two three bricks
and they have lots of half built bridges
and they never make it all the way
across let's say you're a videographer
or you like video stuff skills stack
exponentially you got a video skill now
you got an editing skill now you
understand social media messaging
copywriting and branding ooh management
and operations and leadership see how
that person starts to expand you can
imagine how their pay is going to
dramatically increase because now you're
a cmo broadening your horizon and going
deep in these other silos then all of a
sudden you're an entrepreneur one is you
have to make that decision that you're
not going to spend all your money on
stupid stuff the second is that you are
going to spend your money not on the s p
but on the s and me
what
is that you're going to spend it on you
because that thing is going to compound
a hell of a lot faster than 10 a year
you can double triple 10x your earning
capacity the people who are the richest
people in the world they make a thousand
times more jeff bezos made 40 million
dollars an hour last year
it's a lot